BHey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcasts for Monday.
Fucking May 22nd.
Is that a record for how quickly I said the f word? Uh,
I'm actually doing the podcast right now, riding in a car.
I'm not driving.
I'm on my way to a New York City cause I have to do some promotional stuff here
for a efforts for family that's coming out this week, right? Or next week,
May 30th. I don't know what, so this begins, oh,
Billy red face shown his freckled puss on anything I can get myself on.
Um, you know, so whatever. I'm driving in New York and you know something,
there's all this fucking traffic and I going to take an early flight tomorrow
back to La and don't have time.
And my wife just sent me this whole thing on what successful people do and they,
they, they fucking, you know, they uh, I don't know what they do. They,
they, they know how many minutes are in a day.
Evidently there's 1,440 minutes in a day and they use this wisely and they
delegate, right? They delegate shit. Like, I don't want to do that.
You know how to do that. Right. All right, I'll pay you to do that. You know,
a small portion of what the fuck I'm making. I got to get better at.
Then in order to delegate though,
what you have to be is you have to be social and uh, you know,
that's not my thing. And I said I had a couple of drinks. Other than that,
I'm kind of a curmudgeon. I don't know if you've noticed.
I'm a little bit grumpy, but a fucking cruising now.
What other traffic though?
Now watching this will be like a Thursday when it does going to get to do the
whole hour. Um, so anyways, I just got back from, uh,
my tour up there in Canada, work with Nate Craig who murdered it.
If you don't believe me, ask anybody who was in Winnipeg,
Saskatoon and uh, Regina.
And uh, first of all, I'm very proud that Nate and I did a show,
two shows in Regina, and neither one of us went with the easy joke. No,
we did the stupid rhymes with fun. Nobody's like vagina, Vagina.
What's up with dad? I thought there was going to be a giant Twat here.
Sinkhole flash thing. We are kind of left it alone and
um, I don't know. We had a great time for questions. Let's just back it up here.
Okay. We start off in Winnipeg.
I told the people at Winnepeg that I wasn't going to tell people this,
but I just think there's so off the beaten man path. It's fine.
The cuisine in Winnipeg, it's fucking insane.
All right. Jesus. What's the, was the name of that place? We actually,
I didn't have time to go this time. I, uh,
ordered from this place, the peasants something or other.
It was my little list of places to go. Scrolling down to Winnipeg.
They, I thought that was going to be a bunch of traffic. Oh,
he's just blocking
me up. The driver. Yeah. I peasant kitchen.
Get the torchy air if you're ever there. T, O. R. T. I. E. R. E.
It's French pork pie and a,
then we went to the tallest poppy for breakfast the next day. And, um,
I wouldn't have known about either one of those shout out to, uh,
a Canadian by the name of Ed Robertson.
You might've heard of them plays in a band.
I think he's in a garage band or something like that. You might've heard of him.
I Dunno. I'm just fucking with you. Um, so anyways, uh, the food
was unbelievable up there and uh,
the shows were awesome.
Played in this old theater and I forget the name of, I don't remember.
It's been around since like 1900 and up top. They have like the,
the same old shitty seats they used to have back when everything was segregated,
you know,
and all the white people were downstairs and anybody else had to walk all the
flights of stairs to go upstairs, you know? And what's the result?
What's the result have 50 years later,
white people are getting their asses kicked in sports.
You know why we got no quads, we don't have any glutes.
That's why our acids is so flat. We just used to walk into the theater.
We were on the ground level and everybody else had to walk up. Right.
That's why we get our asses kicked from the Gridiron to the Dojo. It's true,
but all comes back to going to see Harry Houdini and not having to work for it.
Um,
so we were actually there and it wasn't cold as shit like the last time and a,
you know, try out some new stuff. Everything was going great. Um,
went to bed the first night and have a drop of booze. How about that? Huh?
Didn't smoke a cigar. You know, there was Cuban cigars, but you know,
it's Canada, so they got Cuban cigars, but there's no place to smoke. Uh,
they're very, uh,
they're very hostile against smokers or they just maybe like overly protective.
They sort of helicopter parent with smokers up there. And you sort of,
I guess allowed to do it outside. Although I did not,
I didn't think I really saw anybody smoking anywhere. Um,
so anyways, we did that Gig and uh,
the next one on the docket was we drove up to [inaudible] Saskatoon of speaking
of which there was these two or three concept, the Winnipeg show.
I thought they were booing me, but they were just going to,
I don't know why we were in Winnipeg.
I guess that's short for Saskatoon for like Cleveland,
the land up there, I guess they call it the tune or they just yell out tune.
I have no fucking idea. But we, uh, I thought they were born me. So, you know,
I got off stage and I was just like, Jesus Christ, man.
I thought that was a good show, you know? Um, but I was like, no,
no, no. They were yelling tune. I'm like, what's two?
And they was four for Saskatoon. I was like, all right, we're in Winnipeg.
They're like, oh, yes, sorry. Sorry. That's a big thing in Canada. Everybody,
sorry, I'm, oh, sorry.
Like there's waitress was clear on our table and you know, plate is empty.
And when she goes to clear that, she goes, oh, sorry, sorry.
It's like you're apologizing for,
do you brought food to me and now you're taking it away on, you're apologizing.
It would all the time. Sorry. I'm sorry. Get the puck out. Sorry.
Um, so anyways, we did the drive up from, uh,
from Winnepeg to Saskatoon, the one that everybody was saying, hey,
getting ready, what the hell is that stuff? Ah, Jesus,
that's not pleasant is it? I'm sorry. Sorry, I picked it up.
I'm going to be ridiculously pleasant on this, you know,
fuck those cops who yelled at tune in Winnipeg. Sorry.
Um,
it's funny because everyone was saying I was going to be dreading that drive,
you know, like an eight hour drive and a, so we start,
me and Nate start driving up and we're just hitting all these bugs and shit.
But I got to tell you, man, it was beautiful and uh,
both loved the drive. You know, we live in La,
we're just smashed in with a zillion other people. It's nice to get out there.
What a beautiful country candidate is. Good Lord. Um,
all these, these farmhouses, all of this land,
it was beautiful. And all I just kept thinking was,
I would love to fly a helicopter out here.
Cause if he had a problem he could land at anywhere as opposed to when I'm in
La, I'm looking for fucking soccer fields and playgrounds and opened this,
not kids there.
If I ever had a problem and I'm just up there,
it was just like just wide open spaces and I wasn't that bad at driving.
He didn't like seven hours.
We took the one lane highway instead of the two lane highway.
So we had a lot of fun like peaking around trucks and shit trying to pass him a
lot of farmers like driving these giant tractors down the fucking street,
you know. Um,
I dunno, I,
I got a bunch of pictures of shit that I saw every like every mile there though
there was a barn that looked like it was going to fall down and there'd be some
guy who just had like a zillion fucking cars
or tires or something all piled up in his yard. It was really a,
it was pretty interesting. And I was just thinking those guys from gas monkey,
you know,
if they ever pull all the fucking cars out of barns down in the states,
they could just go up to Manitoba and Saskatchewan. They'd find, I saw a number,
I saw a 65, uh, I'm driving like 70 miles an hour too. And I still saw it.
So 65 Ford Galaxy, I don't know if it was the 500 might've been, no,
I think it was a 64, actually 64. I know he's telling the fucking rain man.
Right, right now. So anyways, and then we get up to fucking Saskatchewan,
Saskatoon and uh, we only had one show that night.
So of course I went out and got absolutely fucking hammered.
Hammered at this bar. A lot of tattoos, a lot of tattoos up in Saskatoon.
Yeah,
a lot of tattoos. Sorry.
Um,
but it was a town, it had this amazing park and um,
which I forget the fucking name of and I got up the next day cause I sham all
those years, they haven't yet paper route.
Like I can only sleep for so fucking long.
I just sort of naturally wake up so you know,
I didn't get to bed till like two in the morning.
I still woke up at like eight 30 and I was staying at that.
They're fucking a red room hotel.
There is this beautiful old hotel that looks like you could have shot the
shining in there and uh, it's right next to this long parking.
I just was watching to get a little mini waterfall.
I watched these pelicans trying to fish.
I saw some geese for some baby geese walking around.
It's crazy for all these years of living in New York and La.
I was just sitting there geeking out and there was some old lady standing there
looking at the goose and Rakusus like putting its fucking head down looking at
her and I'm thinking that's like an aggressive posture.
So I walked away but I was also looking, sorta laughing,
like thinking that goose was going to fuck the old lady up and then thinking
like, what would I do because that would be bad. I mean,
I can't walk away from the Old Lady,
but I also don't want to slap the shit out of this goose in front of all of its
children. So a sort of a tense little moment there, right in nature. And now,
fortunately a cooler heads prevailed and everybody went their separate ways.
But the, I don't think you'll lady knew how close she came. You know,
she had a big grin on her face as the thing was like duck and downloads.
So she's kind of ducking down, like imitating it. Um, you know,
like she's looking at a gorilla and she's pounded in her chest and I thought for
half a second, like I was going to see some like, you know,
some fucking old lady bird MMA action, you know.
Um, but you know what? She's so fucking older,
but she knows how to kill a goose.
She's probably went out in the backyard and I can do that shit.
They just walk up and they grab it by the neck and then they do the spin move
and then they just hold on to the next of the body spins.
And it just breaks the fucking thing's neck. Um,
she looked like she was old enough that she actually lived during those times,
you know, back when you earned your meal, you know,
like you knew the name of the thing that you killed. It was like a pet, right?
And weird dreams probably slipped into your fucking sexuality somehow.
You're like dressing up like a bird when you fuck or something like that in some
weird thing where anytime you get abused, you know, file sexually,
I don't know what it is, it ends up making you some Weirdo in the wreck. Um,
so anyways, I ended up doing, so I walked up and I went over the hill,
that river there, whatever the fuck it is,
like walking along these trains tracks and I got to be honest with you,
I was a little nervous about that because it was this old kind of wooden bridge
and I was just thinking, uh,
someone would walk by me and I always kind of made eye contact and like braced
myself because I've just was nervous that someone's just going to grab my legs
and throw me over. I remember seeing a movie a long time ago, this guy did that.
He was a psycho and he went hiking with these people and they didn't realize he
was a psycho. I think he'd already killed people in.
Then he went up there and uh, he went to like take a picture of this woman,
this couple or somebody pushed both of them off the fucking cliff. Um,
and it was so eerily done that I'm like,
this has to be based on a true story.
Cause usually that's not good enough for Hollywood dance to be some dramatic way
they kill you rather than just some creepy real way.
Um, so I was walking across that, that beautiful nature and everything.
Then it was just, you know, worried someone's going to just,
I dunno,
just grabbed me by my ankles and tossed me right over before I realized what was
going on. You know, typical shit had to be so busy trying to save my cell phone.
I wouldn't even think about myself before I went over.
I don't think I could've landed a dog, you know,
I don't think I was that high up.
Um,
what does that say about me then?
I'm going through nature and I'm thinking birds are going to tackled ladies.
If somebody's gonna throw me off a bridge,
uh,
or just awfully conscious cause I know the fucking drivers listen to him. Uh,
anyways, plowing ahead here. Uh,
then we did the drive down to Regina and I don't know, I don't really have any,
we went to some fucking bar. Why don't you know where the Hell I was drinking?
It's the same place they hadn't lunch and I fucking went into, uh,
when I was in Saskatoon, it's right, right out front from the, uh,
from the red rum in that I was staying at. And Oh my God,
that place was a shit show. And this is fucking earliest.
We walked into the bar and the guy goes, can I see your driver's license? I go,
yeah. And then he goes to scan the thing and I like blocked it with my hand.
I go, dude, on scan my id, where are you gonna go? You know,
it's just for us loving me, but the fucking media, but fuck out of here.
He was scanned Nate stuff. It's just like,
I like just the liberties that people take with your Id.
I don't let go of my id any more. Let me see your id and I just show,
I hold onto when they go to take it as this check go. Just read it.
I don't give people my id. You can look at it, you can read it. Um,
you know, when they check into hotels,
they always go to grab it from me and I hold onto it. I know that all, sorry.
Sorry. Can I see it? I go, I don't want you to type any information into your a,
you know, oh, we just do that. So the next time you stay here, now you don't,
you take it and then you sell it and then someone else gets it.
And then all my fucking shits out there. And next thing you know, you know,
I don't know what
somebody defaults on a house and fucking Regina and the banks are coming after
me. I don't know where. I just know it's not a good thing. So, um,
we went in there. Oh my God, those people were fucking party. It was,
it was some sort of holiday weekend up there. I don't know what it was for,
but a lot of tattoos, lot of tattoos,
a lot of sleeves, lot of fucking tattoos. And uh,
I just kept drinking and drinking and drinking and I vaguely remember bringing a
hockey
stick over is a Sherwood that blew my mind because I had not seen one of those
since I was a kid, you know, and they did shots out of it.
And uh, I don't really remember much after that. I just met bud.
I walked out by myself. I do remember that, I think. Yes.
And then the next day I woke up and I did the whole stupid walk.
And when I was done with the walk, there was this little double decker bus
and I was starving. I didn't know whether it was a good breakfast play sank,
just said fuck it.
And I walked up to the double decker bus that they turned into this fucking
little restaurant thing and I had a hot dog for breakfast.
It folded up with a a mid chocolate chip ice cream counter
and I sat alone on a fucking park bench eating an ice cream cone, Saskatoon,
Saskatchewan
hung over his shit and just laughing at myself like,
what kind of a fucking life on my living. So as I'm sitting there,
this nice Canadian couple pulls up, right? They both thought bicycles.
One of them was towing a kid and I just see what the one guy, you know,
they're all like Flander sick. That's how nice they are up there.
And he just goes, he pulls up, he's like, oh, oh no.
Oh No. And I'm like, what's he looking at?
They turned around and I looked back the, you know,
the little busting that they had,
the hotdogs and the ice cream and like 40 children's jet just showed up,
brought up by like the teachers or something.
It's like they were going to be out of ice cream and hotdogs by the time these
people order. It was fucking hilarious.
I beat the Russian just by like 30 seconds,
but like they were just all know, Geez,
well I guess we got here at the wrong time. No, no, no. Sorry. Sorry. It's okay.
It's all good. You eat everything. I don't need nourishment.
They were like even apologetic like that. It was so,
I always forget how loud and obnoxious I am and my fellow Americans are until I
go to like other countries, like I don't want to be the gay shit, not Americans,
because I was up there and he just kept talking about how nice the people are up
there and I was like, dude, fuck these people. They've, they've Ryan, when they,
when they lose, you know, a playoff series. Okay,
they're just as racist or just as fucked up, blah, blah.
By the time we got to Regina, I was like, all right, you know what?
These are really nice people. I'll give it to you. I'll give it to you.
All right. I'm stubborn.
I don't want to be yet another person that travels to another country and then
comes back here to tell everybody how everything in this country is wrong.
You should see how they make a grilled cheese sandwich up there.
I mean it's just so everything's like fuck it better.
It's like really? Is that why everybody's always paying attention to us?
You know, if we stink so bad,
how come you know the name of our president and we don't know the name of your
president? Huh? Want you think about that one for a second? General Bill?
Cause you guys dropped bombs on us all. Fair enough.
All right, 17 minutes. This is like the fucking old days right now.
If you'd like to know I'm going over the Manhattan bridge.
I'm looking at my old digs way back in the day up the street.
I used to live in Yorkville. Think that's what it was called. And it was Rosa,
that depressing fucking Roosevelt Island Queensboro bridge.
I walked across that day one time I was so sick of going to the gym.
I was just like, you know, I ran down. I didn't run for another time.
I fucking walked down, walked over the bridge.
And there's no way to walk on a bridge and not think about that Saturday night
fever, the fucking idiot. You know,
I love how he was too cowardly to get into that fight.
And then he's going to do a headstand on the Verizanno bridge. That's still,
by the way, that's still one. And uh, that goes from Brooklyn to stat.
Now see if I still remember, this goes Brooklyn Bridge, Manhattan, Williamsburg,
then Manhattan. Hey Sir. Is this still a Brooklyn?
I mean system Manhattan or Williamsburg. Williamsburg. How, sorry. Williamsburg.
My fault. So it goes Brooklyn, Manhattan, Williamsburg,
Queensborough and then I don't know what the fuck else is up there.
There's some sort of foot bridge ish. Triborough bridge or some shit.
They probably renamed it. You know, at this point,
it's not the Jackie Robinson fucking bridge. It's probably named after some,
some lady, you know,
I dunno what some lady fucking showed in clam. I show [inaudible]
she was considered brave. You know the, every, twice,
every bridge login they get, I don't do it. Fucking vagina, joke and vagina.
Now I'm going to do it out on a, on a bridge. It's wrong.
Okay.
Um, so anyways, oh my God. Alphabet city. Yeah. Now it's like all nice
Tom Skins, square pack, all the memories of coming back. You know,
I've been gone from this city for so long that there's a lot of it that I don't
even recognize. Like,
I mean obviously the empire state building and that type of Shit Times Square
and that type of thing,
but it's like just a completely different from the city that I moved to.
Like Times Square was fucking scary when I moved here.
Yeah.
So we just drove by,
just drove by us and was driving like 30 miles an hour with the sun roof open
with their cell phone out the top of videotaping. But
I guess I'm podcasting but I'm not driving. Right or do you want to film it all?
I'm sorry. Sorry. It's okay. Sorry. Um, I'll let it for you.
I won't charge her anything. I'm Canadian. Um,
how funny is it that they're that nice and then you get them out on the ice?
That's when it all comes out. Right. Fucking crosscheck into the neck.
What was said? Flanders gets his glasses off,
puts on a different kind of sweater and you'd better keep your fucking head up.
That's Canada, right inside. Please do a drawing of fucking Flanders as a fuck.
A good for the fucking, I don't know,
the Thunderbay Lamas, whatever,
whatever the name of your teams are up there in the fucking lower levels,
the minor leagues, whatever you call. Or there'd be,
every fucking Canadians are saying, I made it to thunder bay and the,
I don't know, I wasn't good enough to get in the NHL.
So I tried to fight my way into the lake.
I know I'm doing a bad Canadian accent. I apologize. But uh,
okay.
Anyways, whatever. Do I remember long time ago,
Jeff Ross hosted a comedy show live from Thompson Square Park.
And I remember thinking that was so fucking Badass.
Anybody that was performing there cause alphabet. See,
like before I even came here, people were saying how scary that was.
Like Thompson Square was just like the city had just given into like,
I mean it was like, that's a subway goal by a or something. Um,
it was just like a tent city. Like I walked by one time and it was just like,
uh, I was trying to mask the fear of my face plus, you know,
rubber neck and just wanted to see what it looked like. And uh,
it was like junkies, homeless people just fucking mentally ill people.
It was like, it was like the beginning of a bad like hair metal video.
You know, when they used to try to do those apocalypse ones,
they were all basically loosely based on the escape from New York.
People coming up on a man holes even what's his face did that Michael Jackson
did it. It looked like it was like the thrill of video except uh, you know,
it was real
get away. Um, anyways, I'm going to read some advertising characteristic.
Getting car sick. Um,
it was funny about having a kid is your screensavers all become your kid and
every time you pick up your phone you just, you know,
you're around other adults and they have no idea.
You're looking at your kid and you just go play ball
and you try to turn it into a cough. Excuse me. Because as a man,
you're not allowed to show love. Um, all right,
content live reads. Okay, here we go. Oh, look at this. Look at this.
Live from the fucking Williamsburg Bridge.
It's old zip.
Okay, a recruiter.
The driver's gonna think I'm nuts. Uh, are you hiring well, are you,
do you know where he posts your job to find the best candidates?
Talk about the challenge of finding great talent and,
or the approach importance of finding great talents
to a successful business. So I think people know that. Yeah, you guys,
you guys didn't know. You know, when you're hiring people,
you don't want to fucking moron to come in,
especially if they're running the register, you know, or your new CEO.
You don't want to dope. You want the best person possible.
So it'd be nice if you could, you can pick from,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of people rather than whatever mouth breather answers your
ad in the local paper. Uh, how's ZipRecruiter is different with sip?
You can post your job to 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology efficiently matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else.
That's why ZipRecruiter is different unlike other job sites is it
doesn't depend on candidates finding you. That one was creepy.
That was like a ghost went by. It finds them. In fact,
over 80% of jobs posted on ZipRecruiter get a qualified candidate in just 24
hours. That's how great this is and that's how desperate people are.
No juggling emails or calls to your office. Simply screen rate,
nice tits and manage candidates all in one place with ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use dashboard, call to action. Find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by all businesses of all sizes to find the most
qualified candidates with immediate results and right now my listeners can post
jobs on ZipRecruiter for free. That's right for free. Oh, that's right.
For free. Sorry, we're driving. Sorry.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time. Hey,
try it for free. Go to [inaudible],
forking recruiter.com/burn sorry, that was my bad New York accent.
A zip recruiter. Novae. All right, car shield.
I have no idea what this is.
Is this a bra for the front of your car so you don't get rocks up on it?
Sooner or later your car will break down. It's a fact. Every car,
truck and SUV owner knows if you're lucky.
It happens while still under the manufacturing manufacturer's warranty and the
repairs are covered. If it happens after the warranty expired,
although you could be out of pocket thousands to get it fixed.
That's why getting extended coverage from car shield.com is a good idea.
A new engine or new transmission could cost over $5,000 transmission doesn't
cost $5,000 all right?
You can go on youtube to figure out how to fucking pull an engine.
You could do it even as simple repairative sensor chain cost over a thousand
dollars skip that hassle man, cause shield makes the whole process like dead.
Canadian whole process process. Sorry. Easy.
You select your favorite mechanic or you can even go to the dealership to do the
work. That's cool.
And there's no checks in the mail stuff or waiting for reimbursement.
Car Shield gets the mechanic pay directly.
Car Shields and administrators even give you VIP treatment providing 24 seven
roadside assistance and a rental car while your you always just in the shop so
you're not left stranded out in the cold or you guys could maintain the fucking
engines. It's funny,
the engine blocks made out of fucking steel sounds. The transmission,
if you just keep it looped up, I mean theoretically it could last,
but who knows? Who's kidding, who. You're not gonna fucking do that. Are you?
So get cars, shield. If your car is three to 12 years old,
it doesn't mean you have to pay high repair bill bills.
Car Shield administrators have paid out close to 2 billion in claims and they're
ready to help you. Save yourself thousands of potential car repairs.
Get covered by the ultimate and extended vehicle service protection before it's
too late. Visit [inaudible] dot com slash bird to save 10% that's car
shield.com/bird to save 10% of the deductible may apply in a bunch of other
shit. Be careful with those guys, man. There's always some fucking thing.
They're extended warranties. Maybe they're the good guys. All right. Upside.
How many more of these God damn things are there? Two more. Two more,
and then I can start people watching like I used to do back in the days, shit,
and all over their body. All right.
There's a better way for you to buy business travel.
It's called upside.com every time you buy a trip, it upside.
I'm just reading this fast so I can get through a,
you'll save your company a ton of money and they give you Amazon,
Amazon gift card worth hundreds of dollars upside upsides,
able to do this because they bundle your flights and hotel together for one low
price bundling. Pricing saves money. Goddammit.
If you're a frequent business travel,
your company saves a ton of money and you get thousands of dollars a year in
gift cards just to go.
How many hookers you can get when you fly over to Thailand just for buying your
air and hotel together at upside. Plus you still get all your miles, man.
If you're shopping for business travel,
you'd be crazy not to check out upside.com crazy. I don't know about crazy,
but you know, probably foolish.
It takes just three minutes to see how much you can save by buying your flights
and hotel together for one low price.
And right now you can use my name bur you're and you're guaranteed to get at
least a $100 trip. 100. I'm sorry, 100 on a dog trip. You know,
fucking burger king, $100 Amazon gift card for your first trip. That's my name.
Burb you are to get at least $100 Amazon gift card.
Save big on travel and get a big gift card every trip.
Um, evidently I love upside.com even though I'd never used it.
upside.com minimum purchase required C for complete details. All right,
here we are at graffiti graffiti, New York.
Somebody wrote Elvis for some goddamn reason,
or let me get some New Yorkers here. Where are they? Oh, we got a red light.
All right. stamps.com everybody.
I use stamps.com just I'm coming off the bridge, by the way. All right,
coming off the bridge.
I use stamps.com to send out anytime a worn myself out to send out my posters.
Stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use that time to help grow your business. I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer and printer and the mailman picks it up.
Avoid the hassle,
man of post office and mail everything from postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments. Click print mail and you're done.
Unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for your letters or packages at your convenience.
27 seven days a week. A key words to describe it or any bed.
Evidently a convenient, easy, reliable, flexible,
ah, dirty ass. New York. Look at these fucking people. Oh my God.
Kids playing outside in New York,
unsupervised little kid acting like he had a gun. No,
this is like the Old New York.
I know this is going to be all like fucking high end. Now
[inaudible]
is, that's not a crazy guy. That's an artist. Who is he talking to himself?
Robbins sold gold. Cash
by gold isn't all only Asian looking woman.
They're leaning up against a dirty poll.
What the fuck am I? Hell. Essex Street and de Lancie. I never, yeah,
used to be down here. All right. Convenient, easy, reliable, flexible.
Right now you can enjoy the stamps services with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com. Click on the microphone,
top of the homepage and type in bur bur that stamps.com enter bar stamps.com.
Never go to the post office again.
Um, all right. Down here, like around Houseton Street.
Back in the day I used to do this fucking room called surf reality and uh,
it was the beginning of the AllSeen and the level of talent.
This was before you could start your career,
start a privileged career in the fucking old rooms where there was like,
no heckling,
let's just support and give somebody at least 20 minutes to get to a fucking
punchline. This was like club comics going down there.
And then just some Weirdo people that you know,
just were just totally different. But all the comics loved them.
And I used to do a place down here called surf reality.
And I remember every time I got off the train and I walked over here,
I used to fuck, I was convinced I was gonna get mugged. And uh,
I bought this jacket from the army navy store in a black fucking hat trying to
look like I was in nom or some shit. And uh, you know,
keeping my head down so they didn't see the fucking Ron Howard look on my
goddamn face, you know.
Um,
you know, what's great about this is, is as I look out this,
I might be able to do a whole podcast and not bring up what is happening to my
Boston Celtics, Jesus Christ. Everything that I feared finally happened.
I told you guys when he first started watching him, I'm like,
how could a team that doesn't really have a center that doesn't rebound,
is not good playing d in the paint and lives and dies by the three?
How can you win in the NBA? But they did and I bought into it.
And you know what a big bucket of reality hit us and gave us the old right
there, Fred. I don't know if game three is tonight, but after watching game two,
Jesus Christ, I was, I was so excited.
Least we got the number one pick next year I'm going to go out on a limb and
say, maybe we should get a center.
What are you guys sick of, man? You still believe Kelly Olynyk.
If the rest of the team can somehow get us to game seven,
I'm warning you people in Cleveland Right now,
you better watch out for Kelly Olynyk.
That is a bad man and games seven games one through six,
he's fucking horrific. But you get that man to game seven lucky seven.
That's who I,
that's what I call lucky seven with this Kobe 11 elevenths brings to Celtics to
have in some shit. I don't know if it rhymes. It's true. Um, I don't know.
After game two, I'm wondering if we're even gonna make it to game four.
I mean we lost by 54 fucking points.
That's like some shit that happens when you're like in middle school.
Um,
but his, there's a part of me that actually enjoys this because,
um,
I'm rooting against the warriors and I think it bugs Lebron and the Cavaliers
that we were the number one seed,
I think it bugs him that they acted like we even remotely had a shot against
them. And I know Isaiah's has, we
just found that out. But come on, he's heard. So what we only lose by 34 points.
Um, I think they just got a chip on his shoulder,
did the defending champs and nobody is talking about them like they are.
And everybody's up the fucking ass. You know, the old, the bosses sell to two,
they're a number one seed just trying to sell this series right now.
Everybody's out there talking about the fucking,
the filthy Golden State Warriors,
kicking people in the balls and blowing out fucking ankles and shit. Um,
I mean, has it been a more boring western conference or Eastern conference?
Matchups I mean, these things have just been absolute blowouts.
I bet they calling up stern again and he's going to get those mobbed up for
Epson, then fucking start fixing some games again.
Just so they don't lose out on all this ad money because these things are just
going to go,
they're going to go for games rather than they haven't 14 games possibly of ad
money. They're going to have the bare minimal eight, you know, and these owners,
man, they got a lot of money they have to pay out to these players. You know,
they spend a lot of money with their hookers and all that type of shit.
You know, getting the fucking tummies talked,
lap band surgery and all this ship getting their faces yanked back so they can
keep banging the underpaid cheerleaders or whatever it is that they do.
So everybody, I've, everybody's is basically waiting for the finals and um,
I don't know, man. I, I don't want to jinx it.
I'm going to shut up cause I already jinx the fucking city of Washington
by just saying I don't want to jinx it. But, uh, I think, uh, uh,
I'm not going to say what's going to happen.
I'm just saying what I would love to see. I, I want to see the Cavaliers win.
I want to see them go fucking back to back and I want to see that fucking
Dream Team of a, I don't know, I can't say a bunch of free agents. Just,
I don't know. I'm just all cunty because I wanted to see the fucking,
I wanted to see the thunder, see if they could get by him.
I didn't want to see the fucking,
one of their best guys just join the Goddamn team. Um, can you imagine that?
Like back in the day. You know,
like when Larry Bird steals the ball from Isaiah can imagine the next year,
like Isaiah Thomas was a Celtic then we just like kicked the shit as a fucking
guy staring at me. Like, why I'm doing this recording right now.
I just waved down and he continued to stare at me and now I'm feeling like,
uh, now I'm feeling weird. Oh,
I guess he was looking at the car. It's sunglasses on Jesus Christ.
Is this guy a fucking robot? Why is he looking at me?
[inaudible]
he's got a minivan and you just stay. I'm in a SUV.
I guess if you have a minivan, you fucking,
you take your sunglasses off to look at an SUV, right?
The minivan is sort of the ball is SUV
and the SUV. Sort of the one ball of like a, I dunno, full sized truck.
I don't know how it works. I'm not a redneck. I'll fuck day.
The Handmaid's tale on Hulu. Is anybody watching that?
I came home the other day and my mother in law, she always,
she watches all these shows that I would never see.
She started to watch one about the,
it was about this girl who committed suicide and left like a tape that she was
watching. That one I would say it's like little house in the prairie meats,
like an s and m video. It was really weird. I got,
I don't know what was going on like they would,
they would like these nuns and they were trying to escape this thing and one of
them makes it on the subway and the other one doesn't and then next thing you
know they got her tied down in there beating her feet.
How do you get that job?
You official like feet beater.
I could see like back in the day, you know what I mean? Back in a while.
Maybe this was, no, this was seems to be like in the future.
Do you realize that there's people out there that they're born in at some point
when they try to figure out like what am I good at?
Like the answer to that ends up being torturing other human beings.
How fucked up is that? Right. You know what I mean? Just like,
it's kind of like being like a comedian either funny or you're not.
You can't teach somebody to be funny.
And then there's like the like tortured some.
You just can't teach somebody to be able to do that. Just like block it out.
If somebody's fucking screaming this I,
you've sitting there screaming and crying,
that guy's just just whacking the shit out of her feet.
I always come always as my alarm. Like Jesus crying, what the fuck?
What the hell you're watching? She always left. She's like, I don't know.
I just put this on. All
right, so here we go. Jesus Christ. You know,
I got to give it up to the graffiti artists.
Like they've really taken it to another level
in certain tattoos I've noticed, you know,
there's like that high level tattoo artists are amazing.
But the problem is is most people that get tattoos don't have a lot of money.
So like,
you know what's the worst is when you see somebody go into a tattoo parlor and
they're looking at shit on the wall and it's just like, dude,
that's going to be on your body for life. You don't even have like a,
you don't have an idea, you don't have a theme and see a,
I don't know,
kind of like a butterfly with like a B.
And that's what's going to end up happening. If you look on a wall,
it's either going to be a skull.
What sets star Tattoo that everybody has that red fucking black one.
I don't know. Like three comedians that have them.
A couple of boy band guys have them. I don't know what it is.
Maybe it's an anime thing. I have no idea. That's my new word enemy.
Cause I'm watching that fucking one punch man. Uh, anyways,
let's get back to the Celtics. Holy fucking shit. You realize we have lost,
I think
we've lost by like a total of like, like north of 80 points
in the first two games. Definitely north of 70. Like,
if you took all the,
if you just had the Cavaliers win by one end game one and then one in game two
and you just gave him all those other points, like they would not,
they could have me in there. Oh, who's kid? No, me.
You get to be in there for about a quarter and a half. It's all tied up. 78, 78.
Um,
Jesus Christ. I mean this is like one,
this is the worst beating a Celtic team has ever taken in my life in the
playoffs. Uh, the, uh, the other closest,
most humiliating one to this was,
I don't know if a lot of people don't remember this during the Larry Bird era
and it was the last year of Bill Fitch. She'd kind of lost the team.
I guess they blame the coach. I don't know how,
but we got swept by the Milwaukee Bucks and I remember we lost game one and we
lost game two and then we lost game three and I just kept thinking like,
they're going to turn it on and they're going to turn it on.
And then they lost game four and that team had Larry Bird, Robert Parish,
Kevin Mchale a, I don't think we had Dennis Johnson at that point.
And I'm trying to remember who was on the box was Sidney Moncrief.
I Dunno who else? Um,
dude,
I'm so psyched that I already got 40 minutes of this fucking podcast done cause
I have no god damn time. Like I was supposed to be at this thing that I'm doing.
I was supposed to be there 25 minutes ago. It's five 55.
It's supposed to start at six 30.
So there is some pa right now freaking the fuck out.
And um,
there's nothing I can do about it. I'll get someone else to street.
The other fire engine,
this is just like the fire chief got a little pickup truck.
Um,
oh, they've got a fire engine there, by the way, dude.
Do you see that fucking lunatic, which is plowed into the,
uh, all those people in Times Square. What the fuck is wrong with people?
Geez, I didn't want to like talk about it to give anybody fucking ideas.
Let's get off that subject. Oh, the Adidas store. I love Adidas.
I've always been an Adidas guy. I don't mind Nike, you know, I don't like it.
I was like the Adidas better. You know why? Because no one knew.
Like everyone knew Adidas before Nike came along. If it's Nate Nike,
I don't know what it is. Oh Wow. Look at this. This is down here.
The old fucking
I all subway stop when I used to live on the upper east side and I used to come
down and go to the comedy cellar in the Boston Comedy Club.
What the fuck? Astor place. That's what I used to get off.
And that's when he started looking up all the names of these people.
Like who then what is Astor place?
And I found out about the astro family and they just all just bunch of fucking
slumlords all the statutes. I just started looking them up.
I learned about the triangle shirtwaist fire
people jump into their fucking deaths cause somebody locked the door to the,
uh,
look that one up triangle shirtwaist fire actually read a book on it.
And uh, it was just, I don't know why. I did. It was,
it was the most uncomfortable book since I read, I read the book,
the perfect storm and um,
if you don't want to buy the book, just fucking open it up and just,
there's a chapter,
maybe like a three page thing maybe where the guy describes what happens when
you drought them and it's just like, I dunno, you fucking blood goes cold man.
It's fucking freaky as hell.
Do you know whenever they find those guys in the caves and he's had this goofy
smile on their face,
like those divers decided to fucking swim into a Goddamn cave.
That just then what I love, they're dumb enough to do that.
And then some poor bastard has to go in there,
has to go in there and try to fucking find them.
Why did they just leave them? Why do they,
why don't they just leave them down there? What the fuck?
I don't understand. You know what I mean? Just fucking leave him down there.
Why do you get to spend all that money to go get a swam into a cave?
He went into a cave underwater. Like, what the fuck are we supposed to do?
And that's somebody God damn job. They gotta go down and fish.
You going down there, no one.
You're going to see a dead body when they find them.
I guess they always have this goofy smile on their face because of the last
thing is your body releases.
I don't all this dopamine or some shit. I felt like John Rogan right now,
except I don't know what I'm talking about. A dopamine and you know,
one of those drugs that those fucking ravers take releases that shit. Right?
And they feel this, this level of euphoria,
like the end of your life level of euphoria.
And the next day they'd just eaten like a bowl of Apple Jackson. They did like,
just burst out in tears because it's so fucking depressing cause they fucked up.
They only know what it feels like to dive whichever deadly after you go through
the horror or blah, blah, blah, blah, blah under the water.
I guess it's a nice experience like, hey man, that wasn't that bad.
Um, let's drive. Thanks. I'm out of my fucking mind. I know it. Uh, we're,
we got 44 minutes, 44 fucking minutes. Oh, Jesus.
I used to go down here and I used to do hot 97,
you know, back in the day when everything was fucking crazy,
like three times a year,
rappers would see they have like a gun battle in the fucking lobby.
And I would go down there and whenever I was doing, uh,
whenever I was doing Caroline's, you know,
and I used to headline Carolines on like a Tuesday night and they would, uh,
Louis Faranda used to have to pull the fucking curtain, you know,
so wouldn't look bad. And, uh,
I was doing talents rooms and a, so let's do the white in the black room.
So I used to come down here and I used to try to get some people that maybe saw
me open for a
talent or drew Frasier or fucking Gerald Kelly,
the New York Kings,
um,
rob Stapleton, all of them. I used to do that rooms. Uh,
well, one of the most fun times in my career that I had was,
was doing that stuff. Uh, nobody knew who the fuck I was to go on stage,
you know, expect now people come out, they know who I am.
So then it's like I have to work to lose them.
What back then I actually had to fucking earn it. And uh, you know, believe me,
I, I, I look back on those days finally, but I don't,
I don't miss not selling tickets.
So whenever I come back here, I always think about all of those gigs.
Um,
Capone used to have this room Nell's on 14th street and it was the greatest
fucking bar,
but it was such a hard room for me that one in Labar bet talent had that one and
that one, that fucking room, every time I went there, it was like, I bombed.
Next time I killed, I bombed, I killed. And I,
I can never figure that roam out was I going after Work Party?
And I used to go up there white as hell. And it just either they, you know,
you had basically in the black rooms you have,
you have your opening joke and then that's it. They,
they black people had their very much like Sicilians where it's like you're dead
to them. You fuck up once that's it, you're dead to me over. There's this,
this relationship is done and there's no, there's no, uh,
there's no repairing it. Um,
which is why it's amazing what's her face.
The Fuji Chick there started to get booed on the Apollo and then fucking turned
it around. The hell's her goddamn name, you know,
amazing voice. Cutest health. Four hours late to our shows.
Lauren Hill, Lauren Hill. Um,
whenever I hear the Fuji Music, that reminds me when I first moved down here,
that and, uh, old tank claim 36 chambers.
And what else? What else was I listening to back then?
I Dunno. Okay. Now if this guy's driving like a fucking maniac,
I think he's sick of my podcast here. Um, how far away are we?
Another five minutes. Another five minutes. You know, they're freaking out, man.
What fuck is he going to? Oh yeah, I got to,
I look like I look like I just came from Saskatchewan.
They're going to take pictures, so I can't be looking like that.
I got to look like a, at least bathed today.
Um,
oh dude, I got a fucking 6:30 AM flight today. Oh,
not that puts me in a goddamn mood. My show didn't get done until 12,
and of course I had to go out and have a couple of pops to celebrate the end of
the tour. Um, I want to thank everybody who would seriously,
who came out in Winnipeg.
Everybody that came out and a tooled Saskatoon, sorry about the,
pop it on the PS here and uh, everybody that came out, Regina,
I had a great time. I'm definitely those three cities and now part of my tours.
Um,
now I feel I can go right across the whole southern part.
So I was telling people the next thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do,
do Alaska over the Yellowknife and some other ones. Jesus Christ,
fucking nine foot lady with no clothes on. Do you see that?
She had her ass hanging out of the bottom of her fucking dress
like a sand trap. Somebody fucking divots in it. Sorry. Sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm not that.
Our many price and we stopping to get gas. We tried to make a left. Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Okay.
Yeah. Let's go. Let's go.
We get behind the one polite cab driver in the fucking city here.
Yeah.
Why these people wearing scars? It's not even cold out.
Absolutely.
Absolutely not. Exactly.
All right.
You mean a left? We're going to a left here.
[inaudible]
yeah, at idiot. Yeah. I like you. You're like me.
You just shit on everybody's your drive and then morons. Right.
They don't leave.
Especially with Sunday you got,
it's like dressing Jurassic Park all the times when it comes out.
Forgive me if you're one,
I love what you'd say and Trashmore of a and more entertaining.
It makes me feel more normal cause that's all I do.
Don't you take part of it is because we feel like, you know,
they don't know what we're doing. We're too wrapped up in ourselves.
Or do you think they're morons
when you right and and underlining people is wrong. They makes you weird. Right?
There you go. Yeah. That makes you right. I love it. I'll look at that.
Bill's Barn Burger.
[inaudible]
Oh, there's some flier fan in there with the Clo Jeru Claude,
whoever you say his fucking name.
I said hotels right in the front.
Oh, okay. Right here. All right dude. I'm going to jump out and I'll be around.
All right. I'm just gonna. I'm gonna. I'll be, I'll be back down in like,
I'll be so good at this. I don't think there's a place for me.
You have to circle. Yes. I think you've got my phone number, right? I just,
I think that's tense. Did you text me? Let me call you now. Yeah, call me now.
So then I got it. Then you call me. I was showing him the front. Okay, cool.
All right. You know what?
I'm going to call these people and I'll let them know that I'm coming over.
I don't know why.
Why the fuck do I have to be in an hour early for a God damn podcast?
Like in a warm up my voice. Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck shit. Right.
Um, so your phone ringing, my phone ringing.
Is that you?
No, that's not me. Somebody say hello.
Unless we're in that fucking movie with the guy from Beretta.
You ever see that movie?
The guy who killed somebody or maybe killed somebody got out of jail.
He played Beretta. Remember the, they call them,
the guy did like twin peaks or something. Come on.
You know that not Mulholland drive. What's? What's sick?
Remember the guy from Bretta don't go to bed with the price on your head.
No, I'm gonna call you. Don't do it. Hey,
why don't you just give me a phone and I'll do it. Don't say my number here. No,
it's not three one. Oh, come here. Just give me the gun.
Why do you have one glove on? I'll let you drive and glove and I,
Michael Jackson. Then I use the left hand moves
right with Michael Jackson. I love it. If you got frame, you got frank. I,
you know something. I actually think he did too. You know what? Yeah.
You can't fucking molest a bunch of white kids even if you became white. Yeah,
and get off on it twice. But California couldn't.
They couldn't nail down OJ, right? Oh,
they just want to do a one is the reputation.
That's all they just want you to do. All right. Having said that,
would you leave, would you, would you, if you had a kid,
I don't know if you have kids, you wouldn't leave him with Michael though right
now they're all day cause they could fight him off
on that side so you can feel free to take all your time. I'll be right here.
He just pull up to your house, Huh? Right. Stomping his foot.
Then your fucking kids gotta go up. Alright, I got to hit pause on this.
I'll do the last eight minutes later. All right. Back. Do I need the what back?
Your package? The back. Oh yeah. That's where my best one. My show clothes.
They're in eyes. All right, let me help you. Yeah,
there's like regular clothes and then there's headlining clothes.
I got to get on my head planning. Okay. All right.
Okay. I'll talk to you. It's in a minute.
All right. I'm back. I'm back. Oh, for freckled.
Fucko is back here. I did all my press that I had to
do. I want to thank everybody over at vulture fest, everybody treated me great.
They had a fun time going back and forth.
One of the women over there was giving me shit about how bad the Celtics were
playing and a, you know,
and I was just agreeing with her and then she just kept trying to do a dig on
the Celtics and I go, you know,
I really don't appreciate your little passive aggressive comments on the
Celtics. I'm admitting that you kicking our ass. And then she laughed going, ah,
you caught that. So I go, you know, we're part of Ohio. You're from, I mean,
she goes, oh, I'm not from Ohio. I go, wait a minute, you know, from Ohio,
how are you a Cavaliers fan? She goes, I'm a Lebron Fan. I'm like,
get the fuck Outta it. She goes, yeah, no.
I was a fan of his when he went down to Miami,
and I'm a fan now that he's gone back to Cleveland. He said, it's like,
you know, found out she's from Washington DC. I'm like,
you're a fucking wizards fan. She goes, Ooh, I don't want to do that. It's just,
you know what, I actually respect it on some level. I think that she's a,
a,
you know, if,
I guess if they're all going to be free agents and piling on with each other,
then you might as well be like a free agent fan then it doesn't fucking matter.
Right.
I Dunno.
I don't know when it's brought out. I'm just joking around.
We had a great time giving each other's shit and then I got to sit down.
They um, it was pretty cool.
They actually showed the first episode of season two and from what I heard,
people really liked it. I of course was not in the room.
I didn't want to deal with that.
And um,
and then we went and we did a, uh, I went in,
I did at the interview in front of the crowd that just saw it and uh,
handed out some free tee shirts. We had these,
these condoms made up efforts of family condoms and stuff. Handed them out,
people liked those, took some pictures afterwards is great interview, you know,
just great questions. And that type of thing was a lot of fun. And uh,
knocked it out. So, oh Billy boy,
he's going to be hit in the fucking hotel by he assumed who as you tell him,
I get lifted here. I got to knock out another fucking five minutes.
I might do it tomorrow morning. Maybe I'll do that. You know,
cause it doesn't make a difference because you guys,
I gotta watch the Celtics Man. How much are they down by?
All right. Watch. I even had to turn on a TV anymore. Watch now. Yes.
That's what I want to do. I want to watch now. I want to watch now.
You want to watch? I want to watch TV.
Setting the world on fire.
How much are we down by Kelly Olynyk for the love of God.
Pretend it's fourth quarter game seven.
Whatever the fuck it is you have to do.
All right, come on.
All right. This is football. You guys really gonna listen to me. Channel Surf.
You don't want to hear this shit.
I'm going to watch the Goddamn game and I know dude, live, commentate live.
Not doing that.
Someone's just sit here watching these people getting the fucking shit kicked
out of them. Isaiah is out. I mean we could potentially,
we could lose by 40. Oh my God.
All of a sudden just having a number one draft pick just seems a lot different.
I knew all these fucking people going, like, I'll tell you right now,
the Celtics Somalia player way,
I was at least smart enough to say we're more like a player and a half away.
Meaning we needed two players.
I remember a few months ago where they were trying to suggest if we got Carmelo
Anthony like we'd have a legitimate shot to take out.
Fucking I want said the Lebron James, the Cavaliers.
But that's really what it is. Um, I don't think we deal with that.
I'm going to watch this game. This podcast is going to be like,
I owe you three minutes. Okay.
I really don't because I've done a bunch that are over an hour, but um,
I gotta upload this Shit. I got an early flight cause I've got to go out and uh,
get back to my wife and daughter. That's it. Thank you guys for listening. Um,
and please tell everybody on May 30th thatF is for family is coming out and I'm
going to be doing a bunch of press, so I apologize if you see my stupid face,
a little bit too much out there. I have to do it.
I got to put on the monkey sad monkey hat a little fucking,
you know, do my little fucking dance and, uh, over the next couple of weeks,
but I'm, you know, going to be trying to, I don't know.
I'll be trying to let you guys know where I'm gonna be at if you give a shit.
All right? That's it. Go fuck yourselves and I'll check in on Ya on Thursday.